as many contemplate biden's vaccine
mandate the push to get all eligible
nevadans vaccinated does continue that
is the goal of the clinic happening
right now on the east side of las vegas
orco mana joins us live at chaparral
high school with what state leaders have
to say
orco well brian some local and state
leaders are at this event including ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrow we spoke
to some of them about what biden's
six-part plan means for them
well i'm supportive of that but you know
the private sector has already been out
front especially here in las vegas some
of our gaming companies have required
masks or else testing and i think they
know that if the customers feel safe
because their personnel is safe and that
will help bring back the economy that
was congresswoman dina titus discussing
president biden's plan we're continuing
to effort the thoughts of some of the
other leaders here in the meantime the
emphasis remains on getting nevadans
vaccinated this clinic is aimed at
helping minority communities get the
shot all they have to do is walk up on
stage and get vaccinated
we also asked ccsd superintendent if
biden's vaccine mandate takes the burden
off the school district which was
considering a mandate for employees he
says he applauds the federal government
but he's also still talking with the
unions and the health district reporting
live in las vegas orca mana 8 news now